we're going to take a deep dive into the
physics of the neutron and measuring how
long it lives why these new measurements
only recently completed
will allow physicists and even
cosmologists a better understanding of
how the first elements were formed in
the universe come along in this
fascinating world of neutrons it's
indistinguishable from magic
recently at los alamos national
laboratory an experimental team made a
phenomenal breakthrough in precision
using what's called a bottle experiment
the fundamental lifetime of one of the
most important if not the most important
actor
in the big bang theory and that is the
neutron ultra cold neutron lifetime
experiment
used a quantity of ultra cold neutrons
these neutrons were held in a magneto
gravitational trap and during that
period of time some of the neutrons
underwent a decay known as beta decay
where they shoot out an anti-neutrino a
electron and a proton these decay in
about 15 minutes but getting the exact
precise estimate of the lifetime is
extremely challenging first of all you
need these neutrons which are decaying
and shooting off high energy radiation
that's very dangerous and can have
impacts on health and human safety
obtaining a cold enough cloud to hold
and confining these neutral particles
remember neutrons they're named neutron
because they're neutral obtaining the
precise value for their lifetime
symbolized by tau in physics
has huge consequences for understanding
both the origin of the universe and its
ultimate fate
and it gives a way to test using this
cosmic debris from the origin of the
universe
it will allow us to gain a greater
appreciation of fundamental forces at
work inside the nucleus and in fact on
the cosmos at large this experiment was
done at the los alamos neutron science
center this collaboration using
ultracalled neutrons finally achieved a
phenomenal level of precision on the
uncertainty on the lifetime of the
neutron and this is incredibly important
because if neutrons didn't decay we
would have never have existed because
neutrons are the fundamental building
block of all matter along with their
counterpart the proton now protons are
known to be stable at least we believe
they have infinite lifetimes or
extremely long lifetimes but neutrons we
know they have a very finite lifetime
they found
877.75 seconds with an uncertainty of
only 0.039
percent
so this uncertainty that they achieved
is half the uncertainty of the previous
experiment
so by counting how many neutrons remain
after a period of time interval
the neutron decay rate and also the
average neutron lifetime can be
calculated but there are many challenges
one of them is that the neutrons live
for so long they live about 15 minutes
now because they lasted that long but
not longer on average in the early
universe the neutrons could get bound up
with protons to make things like
deuterium and tritium and eventually
those could combine to make helium and
most of the hydrogen and helium and
their isotopes that we observe today are
around because of the decay of neutrons
so neutrons play a huge role in the
formation of light elements that we
observe today as relics from the big
bang
so achieving a large enough number of
decays required statistical precision
in a practical amount of time when they
last on average 15 minutes before the
decay in a highly radioactive
environment is a huge experimental
challenge the other challenge is that
these neutrons you ask where you don't
go down to the store and ask for a cup
of neutrons
you have to produce them in radioactive
decays or what are called spellation
sources they generate neutrons that are
extremely energetic millions of times
more energetic than what is needed to
confine them in a magnetic bottle such
as these researchers use so how do you
cool down a neutron you have to use what
are called moderation devices ways to
slow them down there are many techniques
to do that these challenges were
overcome by a much greater extent by the
lancey collaboration working on these
ultra cold neutrons so researchers were
able to
slow down or moderate the energy of
neutrons and they used what are called
polarized neutrinos so that they could
use a magnetic field as a confinement so
this is an invisible trap an invisible
prism just for neutrons as sort of a
bowl with an open top and it's made with
permanent magnets arranged in what's
called a halbach array to look at
experiments and the challenges that my
fellow experimentalists play is always
so gratifying to me trying to raise the
next generation if you will a future
experimentalist and what could be more
exciting than doing an experiment that
basically traces the properties of these
atomic particles these nuclear particles
back to the origin of the evolution of
the universe so they did so with this
ingenious trap
so therefore the coldest of the ultra
cold neutrons have very little chance of
escaping during the storage period which
has to be many times the length of 15
minutes which is very challenging to do
because 15 minutes is long for a
particle it's also long if you have to
do trillions or millions of these things
if you're a poor suffering graduate
student this process which is called
cleaning they store these neutrons so
cool in a trap for between 20 and 1550
seconds which is twice the approximate
average lifetime they counted how many
were left and they counted the types of
particles that emit
predominantly protons and electrons so
they used a buffer volume between the
neutron source and the trap in which
they were held as a kind of storage
period the buffer also flattens and
smooths out and filters out the energy
distribution of these ultra cold
neutrons getting a more uniform
statistical sample to probe not only did
this technique eliminate
the possibility of losses from the trap
when the neutrons are transported from
trap to detector it also allowed this
ingenious team to map out the energies
and what are called the trajectories
what directions what distribution of
motion do these cold neutrons take and
this is a way for checking for the bane
of experimental physicists and
astronomers all like what are called
systematic errors errors intrinsic to
your apparatus these can only be removed
by doing effectively another experiment
to just look at the source of error and
not the underlying phenomena the
ultracold neutron team researchers also
improved on the way that they analyzed
their data they used what's called blind
analysis different team members using
different computer codes looking at the
same data with the underlying phenomena
effectively subtracted out
to remove potential experimental bias
known as confirmation bias and what was
left was ignorant of the true signal
which they knew was approximately 15
minutes in duration for the lifetime of
these neutrons and remember this is
incredibly important if neutrons lasted
much longer there would have been
tremendous amounts more of of helium in
the universe than we actually observe
impacts on how many stars can form in
the early universe which would impact
the probability and the density of
galaxies so the stakes couldn't be
higher for measuring this effect and
getting it precisely so because of all
these ingenious experimental and
analysis improvements
they were able to reduce the total
uncertainty to a level where the
systematics
are comparable or smaller than the
statistical errors you can only do so
much with systematic errors there's some
residual that you can't get better than
and actually we can extend these
measurements now to improve some of the
predictions and the abundances of things
like neutrino masses and the abundance
of neutrinos and even the light element
abundances which in combination with the
cosmological measurements of the cosmic
microarray background and baryon
acoustic oscillations that myself and my
colleagues work on
we will understand and be able to make
better predictions and simulations about
the ultra early universe remember
these particles are not the only relics
of the early universe but as such they
are incredibly important they trace the
physical properties the temperature the
density the pressure of the early
universe
and every step forward in precision and
accuracy takes us closer to the true
answer and these techniques can be
extended to other branches of physics we
can hope to lead to more and better
improvements upon our efforts to detect
the only particle
known to be elementary but whose mass we
don't know about the neutrino the
standard model of physics predicts that
the parameter that governs these
neutrino properties together with the
vector coupling constant those two
together would fully describe these very
exotic weak interactions these results
bear on the physics of quark quark what
are you doing here telling the universe
that i'm a superhero but one of the most
important properties called the matrix
element and the matrix element in
question that can be probed by these
neutron decay measurements is symbolized
by v up down
the current best value for this
parameter comes from the observation of
nuclear beta decays
with very very complex heavier nuclei
and they're very difficult to measure
and construct
experiments just to probe those matrix
elements but these measurements by this
los alamos team provide more systematic
immune
values that could be important for
studies of the quarks themselves so this
experiment really resulted in a twofer
provided the most accurate and precise
measurements of the neutron lifetime but
it also bears on the physics of quarks
and those properties are incredibly
important for revealing the properties
of matter at the elementary level so
you're going from a composite particle
made of up and down quarks to learning
about the interactions between those up
and down quarks and those are elementary
particles they don't decay into other
particles the way that the neutron can
decay as obviously does occur in neutron
decay experiments so it's powerful
sometimes to hit the bottle to use
experiments like this just conducted by
this collaboration
[Music]